m accueillant bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
vous avez décidé de déposer plein dans
11 et pas d'un peu partout en france
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à le faire
écouter des familles m'ont contacté
puisqu'elles ont constaté que les
desserts des membres de leur famille
poser question bien évidemment parce
qu'il y a eu un silence qui règne dans
ces établissements parce que elle avait
constaté l'absence ou l'insuffisance de
mise en place des gestes barrières
l'absence ou la tardiveté des tests des
puits dans certains cas même une
dissimulation sur le réel état de santé
de leurs proches au sein de ces
établissements qui est particulièrement
visés par ces plaintes les directeurs
des établissements le personnel alors
ces plaintes elles sont contre personne
non dénommée c'est à dire des plaintes
contre it donc elles ont vocation à
viser bien évidemment les directions de
ces ehpad mais est aussi on peut tout à
fait imaginer pourquoi pas les agences
régionales de santé le spect la
responsabilité et et le plus large
possible
à votre avis est ce que les ehpad avait
au final tous les moyens pour lutter
contre l'épidémie de coronavirus écoutez
je constate que dans certains et pas de
les choses se sont bien passées dans les
dossiers pour lesquels nous avons déposé
des plaintes
il y à ce que nous considérons pas
simplement comme étant de simples
dysfonctionnements mais comme étant de
réelle faute pénale
et on ne peut pas toujours s'abriter
derrière la question des moyens
qu'est ce que vous attendez qu est ce
que les familles attendent aujourd'hui
de ces enquêtes
la première attente c'était précisément
l'ouverture de ces enquêtes
préliminaires parce que ce n'était pas
gagné et le parquet de nanterre mais
également le parquet de grasse pour les
pâtes de mougins korian ont décidé
d'ouvrir des enquêtes préliminaires
maintenant il faut que la justice et
travaille sereinement et puis qu'ensuite
il ya l'ouverture d'une information
judiciaire avec un juge indépendant et
impartial
une information judiciaire au cours de
la pièce
les familles pourront faire valoir un
certain nombre de demandes des demandes
d'actes et demande d'audition bref que
la justice et que la lumière soit faite
dans ce qui est disons le un vrai
scandale de santé publique au sein de
cette crise sanitaire
fabien arakelian avocat merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions